hey everyone we are with Sonny Jane from
Sun genomics hi Allen thanks for having
me on the show I'm excited to talk about
the microbiome so what do you think now
as we come up with this like conclusion
and this wrap up about what's on
genomics is doing what exactly triggered
you to wanna do some genomics so this is
a very personal story for me and it was
a journey with my son I actually started
just with the software component of
analyzing microbes of the gut but then
one day my son had a GI issue and we
needed to find a solution and I thought
why not test has got microbiome and go
pick up a probiotic I thought the second
was really easy and I thought the first
heart part would be the hard part but it
actually was the reverse picking up a
probiotic was really hard to figure out
because I didn't know which strains he
needed I didn't know if they were gonna
cause some worst GI issues than he
already had and I just wanted something
that would like seed colonize provide
provide lasting effect so I started
testing probiotics to understand that
before I gave him any and that became
the foundational data set for Sun
genomics to understand how you can make
probiotics that actually provide health
benefit back to us and you can how you
can custom formulate based off of the
specific species of microbes identified
in anyone's got profiles he can match
them up and make personal formulations
of probiotics and I'm happy to report
that even after taking an antibiotics
and seeing the shifts in these these
gram-negative microbes or these
inflammatory microbes drive up after
taking antibiotics where theoretically
those shouldn't have driven up because
he's on things that knock down bacteria
but it knocked down the good and the bad
and the balance became off right and it
let things just grow and if we had let
it go we think that it could have led to
some of these more severe conditions
that they talked about in the scientific
literature as
allergies etc and diabetes obesity and
even some mood imbalances that they
talked about so we gave him probiotics
precision probiotics and after taking
the probiotics we saw the knockdown of
those gram negative organisms and a
restoration of
good microbes in his gut even ones that
we didn't directly provide began to come
back up seems to be that the analysis of
the gut like you did and then provide
with persistent probiotics on behalf of
your son doing it with this purpose of
making sure that he's got a really good
foundation moving forward is something
that let's figure out how to apply that
to as many people as possible to provide
that with that yeah once we understood
that this technology could be used in
this way it became my mission at that
point to see if I can help other parents
see if I can help adults understand
their microbiomes and any issues that
they're suffering from and we found
through conversations and health goal
calls that a lot of people have GI
issues that they don't necessarily talk
about transparently but when you when
you have a private conversation with
them they begin to help explore and
provide that information back to us and
and then we can really empower them
right and then we can really show them
what their microbiome looks like and
provide precision probiotics so they can
take control they can see how it's
improving their gut and trend and track
that information over time and and this
is a little bit beyond just the
traditional sort of food diet exercise
recommendations that you would get you
can now actually take good microbes to
provide to the other microbes that are
living inside of us a restoration if you
will
in in the event that something is off
balance or what they called dysbiosis
yes our mission is really just to
integrate microbiome health information
into the daily lifestyles of individuals
and cure dysbiosis by the year 2021 so
that nobody has to suffer from these
chronic conditions hell yeah oh yeah
and it started with your kid and now
let's see if we can get it to everyone
to cure dysbiosis by even the early
2020s let's see if we can get it into
the hands of everyone to be
understanding what's actually going on
in here and getting precision probiotics
targeted towards that we're ready for
this technology to to really get to the
masses and excited to help people and
we're excited to have some genomics as
partner with simulation in the moving
forward of biotech and precision
probiotics into the world we as the this
roaring media arm for you and you as
this roaring science arm for
understanding what's going on here and
providing people with that precision
probiotic thanks Alan it's really
appreciate the time thank you
sunny we greatly appreciate you we're
all counting on you keep up the good
work
Thanks thanks everyone for tuning in and
hearing this out about some genomics
check out the link in the bio for more
information and we'll catch you soon